[Music]
power couples were out and about last
night hey guys I'm Denny direct oh and
there are three celeb lovebirds we got
to talk about today
JLo Nicole Kidman and Chrissy Teigen
were all being honored last night
with their respective meant right by
their side so who had the best date
night well let's start with JLo and a
rod
Jennifer hit the time 100 gala with her
beau in tow who at one point had no
problem stepping to the side to let his
lady who was one of the Nights honorees
have her moment but that didn't mean he
couldn't grab a shot for himself of JLo
who I swear is aging backwards a rod is
Instagram husband material you know what
I'm saying the way he dotes on her well
that's love
I mean he's Michelle Turner got to see
that firsthand I've asked you before
what it is about her that you know makes
you love her and you talk about her dry
her work ethic how much of a boss she is
when she says by the way I'm on the time
100 list what do you wish her yet
I'm just so kind of flattered to be
sitting here kind of in the bullpen in
the bleachers talking about the bronze
just kind of watching her and she's
getting everything that she deserves and
it's just really really nice to see you
guys seem like you're in a very good
place there's great energy do you feel
like this is like you've really just
found a groove in life that feel that
way you know just really great time in
our lives happy personally
professionally the future is super
bright and I feel like we we both feel
like we're just beginning that we're
beginning a new chapter of our lives
in every way and it's exciting you know
it is so great that you know I get to
see how gorgeous she is in the inside on
the outside and and a night like tonight
it's such a special night in New York
City I'm just so happy to see her kind
of get her do it ladies get you a man
who reps you like a rod and lets you
shine bright Nicole Kidman knows what
I'm talking about
she was also honored at the time 100
gala husband Keith Urban of course was
there to support and here's what he
gushed about when it comes to his wifey
when Nicole says oh by the way honey
by the time 100 listen what do you say
what's your crowd of her it's so right -
she's got such a beautiful heart and a
collaborative spirit I think she's
talking about these directors but
there's collaborative spirit is so
strong that it's only right that these
things have happened in the
collaborations
weren't you just the other night having
a little like sing-along Mickey all that
a song hecklers get up and sing for that
and so she did I didn't I didn't think
she'd get up so I was Freud I learned my
lesson I was ever happen again well
listen heckling or not the admiration
for each other is so real and there have
been some divorce reports war swirling
but they both seems so mad for each
other don't they which brings me to the
ultimate relationship goals Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend the expectant
mother received a big honor of her own
in New York City as the couple prepares
to welcome a baby boy in June getting in
the war today for being the heart of the
city this is big for me because
obviously food is my complete heart and
soul to be able when we were actual New
Yorkers being able to be here and help
out City Harvest any chance we got was
really important I'd always sell John at
the auctions and I would I like we've
raised millions of dollars literally I
would never I didn't know I could I
would be sleeping with somebody that
could raise millions of millions of
dollars in a single night but where is
this going
oh gosh we're carrying multiple purses
is pretty good she got a lot of purses
for her second birthday and she can't
really decide which ones her favorites
[Laughter]
listen the way John and Chrissy finish
each other's sentences and probably the
sandwiches too is the level of marriage
I want to be act hard to compare but who
had the best date night they all looked
100 last night so that's a draw and the
ladies each also had sweet Instagram
posts about their evenings JLo shared
this selfie with her man and said always
feel blessed to share special moments of
my life with this beautiful soul not to
be outdone Nicole Instagram great night
last night loved sharing it with my love
and Chrissy Teigen well she was proud of
her work and her honor but said now it's
time to hide and get this baby ready for
the world close call but the cutest
couple of the night I think has to go to
jail oh and a-rod they looked like a
million bucks
were so sweet on each other and after
JLo hit the stage at the gala
they after-party with Jennifer's mama
they hit New York's Polo bar at 11:30
p.m. arm in arm and if that's not
adorable well then I don't know what is
folks but what do you guys think you
agree which couple are you sweet on let
us know and I'm gonna head out while you
do that be sure to like ensure today's
episode and I'll be back tomorrow with
another dose of daily Vinny and as
always you guys can catch up on these
stories and these couples at et
online.com slash daily denne all right
I'm out